(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(upbeat music)
- It is such an honor to be here
among all of these brilliant speakers
so thank you so much for having me.
Human beings occupy two worlds,
the real world is what
actually happened in the past,
is actually happening right now,
and will actually happen in the future.
And while we certainly
think about that world,
we also this enormous amount of time
considering all the many possible worlds.
What philosophers and
psychologist typically
refer to as counterfactuals.
That is all the ways
that the world could have been but wasn't,
and all the ways that the
world could be but aren't.
And not only is counterfactual
thinking pervasive
in our every day thought,
perhaps you're doing it right now,
but engaging with these
imagined possibilities
deeply effects us.
It effects our decisions,
it effects our judgements,
and it effects out emotional experiences.
And from an evolutionary perspective,
this initially seems a
bit surprising, right?
Well, it's obvious why engaging deeply
with our actual real experience
would give us some sort of edge.
It's less obvious what we get
from engaging so profoundly
and emotionally with these
imagined worlds as well.
And this seems particularly paradoxical
when you consider the
huge proportion of time
that very young children are engaging
with these imaginary worlds.
In fact, as soon as babies can talk,
they immediately begin
talking about the possible,
in addition to the real,
they begin to spontaneously
produce symbolic play,
substituting things like a mouse
from a computer for a telephone.
Very early on, around 18 months,
there's even evidence that 15 month olds
are recognizing pretend sequences
that are produced by adults
in their environment,
so that's pretty early.
So, why, right?
Why would very, very young children,
who by their very definition
have so much that they have to learn about
the actual world, spend
so much of their time,
and energy, and resources,
not to mention the resources
of their caregivers
who are responsible for them,
engaging with unreality?
Right, we have to answer this question.
So classically, psychologists,
including the father
of developmental psychology Jean Piaget,
but also our friend Sigmund Freud here
who pops up all over the place,
offered some pretty
uncharitable characterizations
of pretend play in childhood.
They essentially attributed its prevalence
to children's inability to differentiate
between the products of their
imaginations and reality.
Between fantasy and reality.
Decades of research have
shown that, to the contrary,
children are actually quite proficient
and sophisticated at distinguishing
between real objects, events, and people,
and those that are products
of their imagination
and the imaginations
of other's around them.
I'm gonna give you just
one example of a study,
this was conducted by Jackie Willy,
just to show you how this work
is typically done with kids.
A child might enter a
room with three boxes.
They'll watch as an experimenter
puts a pencil in box one.
Box two is left empty, and box three,
the child is told to imagine
that there is a pencil inside the box.
Afterwards, the experimenter might ask
the child a bunch of questions
and engage with them.
One of those questions will be,
is there a pencil in box three?
And children have no problem with this.
They say, yeah, sure, right?
They have no issue with
transporting themselves
into this imagined space
in which there is a pencil
inside of box three.
But if some person comes
in from the other room,
who wasn't engaged in this
fictional context initially
and says, hey I need a
pencil, can you give me one?
Children even as young as
two aren't going to make
the mistake of looking in box three.
They know there's no
actual pencil in there.
Instead, they reach into box one
and give the experimenter
what it is that they actually asked for.
So even though children
spend hours and hours
of their lives pretending,
they know that they're pretending.
And this ability then, to
adopt this counterfactual
or false premise, like there's
a pencil inside of this cup,
to make inferences about
events that might happen
in a world in which there
were a pencil in the cup,
but also to separate that imagined space
from the real world is already present
from as early as two years of age.
This is very, very early on.
In fact, there's other prominent features
of pretend play that
suggest that it's the result
of competence rather than
cognitive limitation.
So it's largely unique to human beings,
it's often social in nature,
like many of our more complex functions,
it becomes increasingly
elaborate over time.
You'd expect the opposite
if it was the result
of a cognitive limitation.
Young children do this
object substitution,
as they get a little bit older
they don't even need objects
to scaffold their pretend play with.
They just imagine things,
completely imaginary events.
A little bit later, they might develop
an imaginary friend or companion.
This is an entity that has
a consistent psychology
that they interact with over time.
A rich and complex
psychology in social life.
Even later in late childhood,
and adolescence even,
children engage with paracosms,
the little micro world that they construct
of their own design,
and, of course, as we know, this extends
into adulthood as well.
We all appreciate fictional artifacts
and this is continuous
throughout the lifespan.
Given that very young children
engage with imaginary worlds,
which seems obvious,
and that this engagement
doesn't stem from their confusion,
which is a bit less obvious
but not so much anymore,
then why are they doing it?
Why are they doing it and how?
How are they doing it?
Well, we know that play is characteristic
of young animals across
a wide range of species
and that the behaviors
that are involved in play
are also those that will
typically be most important
for adults of that species.
And in this way, play is a
form of exploratory learning.
So the immature animal
can explore and practice
alternative forms of action in low cost,
low risk environment
without any of the pressures
of having to actually
achieve a particular goal,
like staying alive for example,
and, in fact, one of the
most distinctive features,
biological features of human beings,
is our unusually long
period of immaturity.
Compared with our closest
primate relatives,
we've evolved to have this
dramatically extended,
protected period of childhood.
Early, middle, late, adolescents,
after we go to college,
we're still protected in
the spirit of immaturity,
and what we're encouraged to do
is explore during this period of time.
We're engaging in this
exploratory learning.
So while it's sort of easy
to see how physical forms
of exploratory play like
play fighting and hunting,
and climbing, might translate
into later adult skills,
pretend play is, sort of
by its very definition,
severed from reality.
So in order to make
this analogy with play,
with other forms of play work,
we have to really identify the role
that this particular type of cognition,
this counterfactual type of
cognition plays in cognition.
So, to put this in the form of a question,
why might it be beneficial
to draw conclusions
from false premises like
there's a pencil in the cup?
So to answer this question we can consider
how children's minds are
constructed to support
and also to encourage their
generation of a wide array
of alternative possibilities.
And it turns out that new ideas about
children's earliest
learning mechanism suggests
that the very same abilities
that allow children to learn
so much about the world,
and to reason so powerfully about it,
also allows them to imagine
alternatives to that world.
And more specifically, it's
the ability to represent
cause and effect relationships that seems
to underpin some of the ability
to imagine possible worlds.
And, not only that,
but the ability to
imagine possible worlds,
feeds back to facilitate our reasoning
about cause and effect relationships.
So the rest of this talk, I'm going to,
very quickly try to unpack
the sort of theoretical
grounds for making this claim.
So by about five years of age,
children have already developed
complex causal theories
in variety of domains.
Everything from understanding
biological principles
to other minds to the nature
of other physical forces
and properties in the world.
And the question that
motivates my research,
but also just sort of the
field of cognitive development
in general is just how this ever happened.
How is that young
children are able to learn
these abstract, structured,
causal representations
of the world so quickly and accurately,
given the relatively limited
information that's available
to them from their senses.
What's the origin of this knowledge?
And one classic answer from
developmental psychology,
points to the similarities
between children's learning
and learning in science.
And the idea here proposes
that children's early theories
share, in a meaningful
way, structure, function,
and dynamics to theory change in science.
And in particular, that children
just like little scientists
are implicitly formulating
hypotheses about the world,
and then testing and rationally
revising those hypotheses
in light of new evidence
that they observe.
So this sounds a bit far
fetched when you first hear it.
To help you imagine this,
I'm going to show you
a video of this idea.
What this child is doing in this video
is playing with a blicket detector,
which is a toy that we
typically use in my lab.
This is just a flexible causal system.
It's a box that lights
up, which is the effect,
for certain things, which is the cause.
And it allows us to explore
children's causalate
inferences really well.
So I'm just gonna let you watch
and I want you to keep
an eye out for the child
engaging in hypothesis testing behavior,
similar to a scientist.
- We need this on the box
and this on the box, look.
- [Experimenter] Uh huh.
- This makes that light up the box.
- Mm hmm.
- How about this.
That makes the other side.
- [Caren] Here is a new hypothesis.
- Uh oh.
Nothing.
This one's lighted up and this one's not.
So that means.
- [Woman] Here's another.
- What's making this light up?
Hmm.
- [Caren] That's a familiar
expression to those
of us who do science.
(audience laughing)
Despair.
- Oh no.
Oh it's because that this
needs to be like this.
And this needs to be like that.
That's why.
Oh.
Probably the boxes are the wrong way.
- This was the child's
idea, pretty imaginative.
(audience laughing)
And like in science, it
ends with embarrassment
in front of our peers.
So even though these ideas
about children's learning
have been around for quite some time,
recently there's been some major advances
in our ability to formally describe
the cognitive processes
that might be taking place
and the way that this is done
is by integrating developmental psychology
so this kind of work with
computational theories.
So one of the central
ideas in this frame work
is that children's
intuitive causal theories
can be expressed in a kind of causal map
or abstract picture of
how the world works.
A little bit like this.
So for example, sunlight and
water cause plants to grow,
forces and contact cause
objects to move through space,
desires and beliefs cause someone
to act towards a particular goal.
And in many ways, these
causal maps are analogous
to the more familiar
spacial maps that depict
the various locations of objects
in relation to one another.
This is a cognitive feature
that we share with other animals,
including rodents, like depicted here.
So having a special map is useful
and this is mentioned earlier
because it allows for this
non egocentric
representation of knowledge.
It doesn't matter where I am in the space,
I can still represent the space.
This means that it's flexible.
I can plan my route in advance
and think about the different ways
that I might approach this problem.
And it becomes updated as new information
about the space becomes available.
So in similar way,
having a causal map provides
a complex representation
of the causal relationships
or an abstract picture
of how one thing might be
causally connected to another,
and, just like our
special maps, it's updated
as new information
becomes available to us.
So you can think of each
of these different causal
models as a particular hypothesis
that we might hold about the true
causal structure of the world.
So, for example, if I
notice that the flowers
in my window begin to wilt
I might entertain several
possible causal models.
Each of which generate their
own patterns of predictions.
So it could be that too much sunlight
is causing both the dry
soil and the wilted flowers,
or it could be that the
sunlight is actually
causing the dry soil
and it's the dry soil,
right, that's causing my flowers to wilt.
And if I'm holding a causal
model that happens to be correct
and the predictions that it
generates will be accurate
with respect to my
observations in the world.
But if it's incorrect, if I
hold the wrong causal model,
my predictions are going to fail me.
And this will prompt me
to adjust my causal model
to better approximate
the true causal structure
of the world.
So in affect, this process,
the process of early learning,
might be conceived as a process
of comparing possible worlds
and updating those possibilities in light
of new evidence as you observe it.
And critically these
casual maps also include
a means for representing
possible future actions
for planning in the world.
So if we return to the
two sort of versions
of the wilted flowers
that I described earlier,
even though each of these representations
have the save variables,
sunlight, soil, flowers,
the differences in their structure lead
to really different effects
following some action
that I might take on the world.
So let's say I intervene on my dry soil
by watering my plants.
Hopefully what you can see here
is that depending upon which
of the two causal structures
is an accurate
representation of the world,
watering my plants here in the first one
is gonna have no effect on my flowers
right because it's the sunlight that's
directly causing them to wilt.
In the other case though,
watering the soil will
actually have some effect.
And importantly these
interventions could be real.
I could actually do them.
Or they can be imagined
hypothetical actions.
I can just sort of think
what it would be like
if I were to intervene on the
world in a particular way.
And it turns out, that the evidence shows,
that even preschool aged
children are able to do this.
Are able to reason about interventions,
both in the real world and
also in their imaginations.
So this gives us an
extremely powerful tool
for planning and
considering in the outcomes
of potential actions in advance.
We start with a premise
that might be false
with respect to the world
and then we just reason
about the implications
of that premise downstream.
This leads us to the ability
to design new interventions
and to literally change the future
for ourselves and our environment.
So now we have to push the
pause button for a minute
'cause this all sounds really,
really complicated to us.
All of these things are, of course,
happening implicitly not explicitly
but you might be wondering whether
or not kids could actually do this.
So if we return to
pretend play for a minute,
we see that children are
routinely considering premises
that contradict their own knowledge.
They ignore the fact
that the teacup is empty
and they proceed to
wipe up the imagined tea
when the cup is overturned anyway.
Any time, really, that
children are acting out
the outcome of pretend
events, they're necessarily
setting aside their
interpretation, their causal model
of the real world, and reasoning
about the causal consequences
of some pretend premise.
Some other possible world.
And in fact,
it's causation itself that
gives fantasy its logic.
Despite the fact that
children could, in principle,
pretend about anything at
all, it's pretend after all,
if you've ever hung out with children,
you know that they don't
actually usually do this.
Instead, some research
by Paul Harris has shown
that if a child pretends
to spill the sugar
during their tea party, they're gonna opt
to sweep it up with a broom.
If they spill the milk, then
they'll grab a mop or a sponge.
And it's precisely this
unique blend of knowledge
and imagination that really characterizes
early pretend play in childhood.
And in fact, the cognitive
processes that are involved
in pretend play, aren't
only useful for planning,
they're also critical for learning.
For example, children who
create imaginary companions
tend to show increased theory of mind.
So this is just an increased understanding
of the cause and effect relationships
that dictate the psychological
and social world.
So I propose then that
pretend play is really
just a precocious display of
children's developing abilities
in causal reasoning.
It arises out of those
abilities quite naturally.
And that engagement in imaginary
worlds actually feeds back
to serve as an engine of learning as well
promoting these abilities that we need.
So to sort of summarize the
logic in a single slide here,
the long period of protected
immaturity winds up leading
to increased time for exploratory
learning through play.
Exploratory play allows for
more flexible kinds of learning
mechanisms that support the
development of causal models
that slowly adjust to the
environment over time.
These models support
counterfactual reasoning,
it's sort of inherent to the
model to think about ways
that you might change it in order to think
of how things could be different.
And this is initially
expressed in young children
in the context of pretend play
really as early as they can start to talk.
And finally that reasoning
about these possibilities
feeds back to support the very mechanisms
that underlie causal learning in humans.
So I'm gonna end with a quote
from my colleague Alison Gopnik,
with whom I've coauthored
all of my work in this area,
and I'd like to thank
you for your attention.
(adience applauding)
(upbeat music)